Seven billion and counting.
Hi, everybody and I do mean everybody.
Tim Minton at Buzz60.
Earth's population has hit a stunning number.
A hospital in the Philippines has already claimed to have produced the seven billionth baby.
What we know is, five people are born every second somewhere,...
...only two people die every second.
The good news: there's plenty of room.
National Geographic reports that if standing shoulder to shoulder,...
...we would all fit into Los Angeles.
But five percent of us, and you know who you are,...
...use 25 percent of the world's energy.
That's a problem.
And consider this,...
...the last billion people were added in barely a decade.
Mathematicians estimate that to say all seven billion living names out loud would take 200 years.
By which time at this rate, we'd have 17 billion new neighbors.
All aboard.
Buzz60.
Now you know, pass it on.